welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz today I'm
joined by John guest who is an associate
director at Harper Harrison and they are
a specialist property recruitment
business they're part of that LHI group
there's 8 people in the harp Harrison
brand and John manages a team in London
John thank you for joining me remotely
today how are you yeah all good thanks
to Jim how are you yeah I'm good I like
your room for those that can't see
you've got a good little setup behind
you got some is that Portsmouth top
unfortunately yeah what about the boxing
glove that's an AJ find love really yeah
yeah see oh see there AJ Tyson Fury
announcement that's exciting
who fights yeah any positive and
lockdown is a double positive right now
and any thoughts or coming back yeah
John just just a real quick one than
that obviously I know that you've
listened to this podcast I'm assuming
you listened to other podcasts and
recently I've been looking for because
I've just got that sick of listening to
the same podcast and I've been I've been
looking for one recently and I got
recommended one called a hot box in okay
have you seen that ok even the love of
them just I'll just get this in there
early because I feel a lot of people
could enjoy it too but the hot box and
podcast is hosted by Mike Tyson it's
Mike Tyson's podcast and he has another
chap on their quorum members named that
co-hosted with him and they have some
wiki guests on there I mean the one the
first one that I listened to that I'd
recommend everyone listen to if you're
into sports is the interview Sugar Ray
Leonard recently and it honestly may
screw into your books and you'd actually
love it so let me just get that in the
early because it's I've just enjoyed it
so much
it's my coming back as world and I read
mine oh yeah I sit there that's just
crazy
seeing those videos online absolutely
crazy yeah
topic of sports podcasts
for those that don't listen to it my
life football the Peter Crouch podcast
is brilliant
yeah that's been recommended so much can
actually listen to it I need to listen
to it just it's just a bit silly and a
bit funny and he's just too
down-to-earth football up so I mean he's
made a second career for himself fair
play yeah so I get extra kudos for that
as well for sure
recruitment rollercoaster John guest how
did you enter the world of recruitment
let's start there so a bit like nearly
everyone on your podcast wanting to be a
recruit who Sun actually told this story
at our Leadership Summit start of the
year so I think go to university I had a
really terrible experience at college
where I didn't IT and I just had so many
different teachers and you know tried to
throw me out the college and the two
people that I did it with ended up
failing and had to do a third year just
wasn't a great educational experience so
I was pretty much done by this point I
wanted to go out with her
only minor thumb two a-levels in IT I
thought that's why I wanted to do so
I've got a job at the local university
and IT support which was really really
boring
being honest like the students weren't
there for the summer so I can just sit
there playing football manager for four
hours what would even really care they
never find anyone from the department
because it's part of University London
so it was a job for life but I was just
really bored so at the time I loved cars
as well all of my mates were into cars
it was back in the day where everyone
would spend their Sunday nights in
Burger King car park and definitely been
through that phase yeah so when when
Halfords was full of our wheels and not
bikes yeah I thought if my mates want to
buy these parts why don't I just try and
source them and then I can just sell
them okay make a profit so I ended up
starting doing that and it got to the
point where as so many people coming to
me that I didn't actually have time to
do my job anymore so I thought I'd have
to quit so at 19 I left and started my
first business selling car accessories
so i wills and stereos
suspension kits and stuff like that
ended up going hot well I built an
online shop so we had 15,000 products on
there
I opened a retail store near out in an
industrial unit with a friends company I
did that for two or three years and it
was like great fun because you're
combining what you love with your job
but I had no idea what I was doing in
terms of business I just be by selling
for a pound and sell it for one pound
ten then that's right so this was back
before social media so we went on all
the internet forums and we ended up
sponsoring a load of them and it was
like marketing 101 really yeah this was
when we had like a live MSN Messenger
chat
well amitin boy it was actually me yeah
it's been a bit creative but after two
three years of doing that the market was
starting to to die really cars coming
out with insurance was so expensive you
wanted to do anything to them the wiring
was getting more complicated I thought I
better get a real job my girlfriend at
the time is my wife now worked for the
local paper in recruitment advertising
oh wow
she ended up speaking to my first
recruitment business who said that
they're looking and she said I know
someone that fits what you just told me
so she hadn't got me my first interview
in recruitment man I went down there and
I don't think I was like the typical
background because I'd already run my
own business I think I was a bit of a
worry but they gave me a shot and said
off you go you can do security engineers
from Birmingham upwards here's a fine
crack on
lovely world a recruitment let's go
exactly work out as you go along and and
what year was that
I mean online is around 2007 run that
wasn't seven so yeah just before oh yeah
global financial crisis in 2008 baptism
of fire
so obviously suggest for everyone's
benefit in context and so that was your
first job in recruitment ended up
working there for nearly three years in
line and then joined another company
and you then obviously worked for for
nearly eight years yeah and then you've
been that hard Harrison for yeah coming
up two and a half years right so yeah I
mean a decade's worth of experience in
in recruitment right so keen to uncover
this so I guess definitely keen to focus
on sort of Harrison and more recently
but I guess how was that first year then
when really you've got chats in the deep
end are always interested to hear about
it how's that I think I'm actually
picked it up fairly quickly my first
year went pretty well before the kind of
financial crisis really hit I was
working in a market security which is
needed whatever
there's gotta be anyway you kind of need
it more in a downturn so I mean it did
take a bit of a hit my second year
wasn't as good as my first but seems it
takes with quite modest didn't really
know any better I think where I come
from working running my own business and
working every hour under the side
working weekends I used to go into the
office on Saturdays used to always try
to be the first person here so she had
the work ethic yeah and what self
motivation because I've been working on
my own running my business with no one's
really honest oops I so the
responsibility I think helps a lot I
really understand that if you're someone
who's willing to be accountable
responsible so my first year went pretty
well second year slightly worse I think
probably ended up doing about 80 or 90
in my second year my first year I think
140 and I managed to get three or four
pay rises along the way in the first
couple of years nice what was the
environment was there a bigger big
recruitment business a small business so
they were based in Weybridge I had about
30 people okay
it was confident I mean this was just as
LinkedIn was coming in so we were really
encouraged to use LinkedIn we still have
a fax machine to send out CDs oh my god
I remember one day someone was messing
around and not to filing filing cabinet
over like an 810 foot tall filing fax
machine punched it you can actually send
out any scene it
and it was just yeah just what you think
so mental I just it was a good good
grounding it was a bit old school it was
a bit like you need to be on the fire
all the time there's no need to worry
about anything else the markets that
they worked in were telecoms foreign
security IT it was run by a good guy but
I just felt after two and a half three
years of something better for me I
managed to get my commission up from
2.5% and when I started up to 10% on a
left now when I started looking around
some companies were paying a lot more
than that well you know I wanna make
something of myself I want to get a
house I wanna go on and achieve what my
potential so started looking around
mm-hmm I think that that some thing is
easy to forget that back then it's
really hard to sort of even have a
perspective of what other open and
businesses my offer or what it might
look like on the other side because
that's just been a huge obviously
there's pros and cons to that right
because now in sport for choice and
there's so many things coming coming at
you but I think is so easy to forget
that I mean what that was in 2007-2008
still sending TVs by fax have no idea
that it's a didn't have email though
because now if you're an engineering
business or a service business you know
you don't necessarily own you probably
owned by someone that was an engineer
yeah so you're not necessarily a tech
specialism so last to bring that kind of
email and stuff in hmm so so then
obviously that's when you went and
joined illegal recruitment that you've
had a real long tenure there I guess you
can link it to sort of when you then
went to HAARP Harrison as well but I
think always interested to hear sort of
your perspective and mindset and
thoughts when you was looking for
another recruitment job and join another
recruitment company I think and
obviously now I'm sure over the last 10
years when you've hired for your own
team like it's really common to see
someone that got the experience that you
did or that first company leave and
there for like a couple of months then
end up somewhere else they might stay
there for long period or end up there
and I think it can be really difficult
for a lot of people to sort of make the
a good move following that first
recruitment job so I guess what was your
what what's been your mindset when
you've looked for some progress your
career basically what was important to
you and how did you approach it um
they're both really really different
you know when I left my first company to
join a league I didn't really have
anything to lose I still lived at home
yeah okay back to myself I didn't have
much responsibility in life and actually
it was a business that was 10 12 people
yeah
he knew everyone straightaway and you
became quite a big part of the culture
on day one we worked in a in a funny
little office in Putney bridge where
some win one room worked somewhere in
the other it was not the nicest office
but it was in a good location good bunch
of people we had a lot of fun it was
kind of the opposite really
and they really allowed you to be
yourself so I yeah I didn't really find
that that difficult kind of felt at home
pretty soon unfair enough I'll be back
the reason I stayed so long was there
was always a new challenge for me oh
yeah I started the division for them
they've never done foreign security or
building services before so I kind of
brought them this idea and they said
well why don't you start a business
within a business broker off a company
years later to be a bit of a separate
entity as it grew but when I moved on
after seven odd years there that was
much much tougher to see I can imagine
yeah that's a whole different ball game
I had mortgage just about to have a
child for the first time actually
started in February with Harper Harrison
in 2018 and William was born in March
Wow
have a seat why is that that's so common
exactly like even moving job or starting
your own business when you have a child
is it is there is this sometimes a
moment where it's level if I don't sort
of change my circumstances or change
something now
I'll find it even more difficult once
I've had the child that does play a part
I think you start to think a bit
differently you know life itself that
doesn't sound too old it does change
your mindset what motivates you and you
tend to reflect on why you're doing this
and you realize maybe that there's a few
things that you'd like to change but
going from a business where you knew
everyone yeah really well to a business
like LHI where he walked into an office
in London it was kind of 60 people 50
people at the time and you know I wasn't
no one could have been hired at a
certain level which was by rare for them
to hire at my level before but it was
scary and I looked around and everyone's
looking back at you thinking this
person's been hired in a level often
above people you know what's he got
really is he actually going to be good
and it's for the honest that instar
brilliantly it took me a change sector
start the family started commuting into
London change company so all at the same
time my first few offers I couldn't get
them over the line so it took me four or
five months to do my first deal going
from doing one every week what every two
weeks with a lower fee that's a weird
experience I had to almost take myself
out have a look at my process and kind
of build it back up again for a
different market it was a different kind
of candidate you were dealing with
mm-hmm it was tough but my confidence
took a knock I didn't doubt myself a
little bit but I kind of had to take
myself back remember why I've got this
far I always had a in my mind when
people join a business it's those that
come in and I'm really loud that never
make it so I was always conscious to
just be kind of humble hard-working you
try and be kind to everyone trying to
get to know people and then let the
results speak and after that initial six
months I think the following six months
I went on to build the most in Europe oh
wow so I had to qualify for a trip to so
the Bahamas which was unbelievable until
I found out I can go
because my dad my dad was was taken ill
but and yeah kind of that was kind of I
felt like I'd arrived after mmm okay so
really keen to dig into this and just
quickly and really keen to dig into that
experience job because I think a lot of
people would have experienced what
you've gone through or might even be in
that hardship right now but just quickly
and because let's just touch on this or
period of you building up a separate
entity within a business at oligo and
what just a bit of context did did you
end up managing a team or what what did
what did sort of the entity look like
before he left just so we know we're got
to in that sort of 770 era spirit as
peak we had a team of eight it's quite a
small niche that we were operating in
but I think it would be fair to say that
we were one of the best-known brands in
that sector
I was always a fan of getting out there
so in other words me as many people as
possible because we recruit recruiting
across the whole of the UK people don't
always quite realize what that means
you know if you've just recruited in
London where most of your clients are
within 15 minutes I was recruiting one
of my best clients was base north of
Bradford no well leave the house at 5:00
a.m. for your half hours in the car to
see them and I go and see it at least
once a year we'd have clients in older
mid have clients in Cardiff I'd travel
all over the place so we get out to
every event possible ended up exhibiting
a lot of the industry events and we just
tried to become omnipresent on social
media mat events so that I always
believe that when a client comes to you
the whole thing is five to ten times
easier mmm when you try to bring in
people that don't have experience you
want to make the path as easy as
possible for them so if you can give
them qualified opportunities where
you've kind of taken control of it come
on to the front end of it rather than
trying to pick it up lay and rest it
against everyone else it's just a lot
more enjoyable experience so the more we
focused on our brand and the more
ourselves out there boy started to pay
back yeah peep-peep to eight so maybe
sort of just answered it my what I just
wanted you to talk a bit about was sort
of an what you put down the woody put
down to the like why that was successful
why you managed to grow it to eight
people or why you managed to make it a
success it clearly sounds like the the
branding piece and making sure that as
you said you was omnipresent with the
niche it was a factor but what were this
or key parts as to why you think you was
able to build that part of the business
or the part of their business from
scratch we think well I Kathak speaking
to as many people as possible and trying
to build relationships in whichever way
you can try and get people to see you as
a human rather than just someone that
can find them CDs you know so hence
going to meet as many people as possible
once they meet you they tend to trust
you more see you a little bit different
to every recruit II you just use every
opportunity to elevate yourself of the
noise you want to be that person that
the client or candidate thinks of them
in Italy think about hiring someone or
making a change so try to instill that
in all the people we hired encourage
them to get out there Courage them to
fail share those feelings with with us
it's fine like if you're not failing
you're probably not taking any risks
you're not trying anything but yeah I
think sticking to those core values of
my client relationships adding value
just not just being a transactional
recruiter and trying when you get into
apply and try and then smother it as
best as possible mm-hmm and what was
your management experience like then
because obviously never done that before
well that's a real common challenge for
a lot of people so what you joined
there's someone that was like right this
is the sort of niche that I'm on
confident can build out would you
support what she went on to do that so
what was your journey in managing so
just spoke about your values which
absolutely love but what was your
journey and management like why actually
started leading in my first company
okay at the age of 21 22 I got given a
resource sir who is actually still one
of my best friends I really
he was bridesmaid our wedding my wife's
best friend so I saw him but I think to
start with I was absolutely terrible by
no means saying that I'm the finished
article now but I thought everyone was
the same as me mmm start it I thought
everyone was driven by the same things
but clearly they're not found but part
of my learning over the years has been
trying to get under the skin of people's
why
and everyone's why tends to be a little
bit different how to motivate them why
are they doing this what they think good
looks like just try and have really
honest conversations in the interview
process and then continue those and we
kind of make it one of our commitments
as leaders in our group now if you've
asked you should know your team's why
hmm that's quite tough because sometimes
people ask you know I actually know I
knew a year ago but do I know it now
yeah because I think it's socially
something that you hear a lot and I
think I think it's a hard question to
answer isn't it it's and I think as you
just said I think it can change it does
involve what was that sorry minds
changed a lot why why definitely
different now than when I started when I
started was just to make as much money
as possible that's to be different
trying to have a bit more of a balance
trying to provide for your family making
sure your health is good is like more of
a balanced view and trying to make the
path clearer for other people mm-hmm and
I think um I think a lot of leaders that
will listen to this podcast will know
that that's important to understand
people's why but I think it can be quite
difficult to draw that out of people
sometimes yeah so I mean you said that
we have honest conversations and
interview and let's carry on those but
how have you got better at another
everyone's different of course but have
you sort of got better at getting that
out of people and yeah still
it's difficult it's difficult leadership
and doing the job at the same time it's
difficult balance to get right and
everyone I've spoke to that has ever
done it and done it successfully then
tip my hat to them is it's two jobs in
one and both of those jobs conflict
slightly but I think just being more
human when I maybe as a leader in the
past I tried to be too much of a manager
and managed by process and numbers and
stuff like that rather than managing as
someone that people could I don't know
what the word is but really just let
your guard down I've never been someone
that takes myself too seriously but I
think I managed a bit seriously okay I
gave in but when you start to be bit
more human and you take a strip of
yourself and share your failings and you
let people listen to your call being
vulnerable yeah you to make yourself
more vulnerable and I think people then
come towards you it's a bit like the
sales process really if you push too
hard people push against you sometimes
if you pull away they'll come with you
so it's a little bit like that for me
and I think noting what you're saying
that doesn't mean that you have to be
their friend I think that can be the
hard thing as well as in because what
you're talking about there is then like
okay what does that mean I have to be
the person down the pub with them or
being the friends with them but what
it's it's not as it it's right you know
people like you and people respect you
and people trust you then I think
they'll they'll run for a revolver for
you
and yeah if they're your friend as well
then fantastic
they're probably more likely to be
honest with you a local level but you
can you can go too far with that where
if someone is too close to you then you
know they almost don't take it as
seriously if you yeah cousin and yet
John the manager there in opposition hmm
John the manager can be a bit difficult
it can be a bit difficult then to get
the manager out of you if you've gone
too far on that that's interesting
okay and
just just on this as we're talking about
this if if I've really made the time to
understand my teams why and the
individuals why within that how does
that then help me as a manager what does
that then help you do well you can try
and make sure that someone's personal
goals marry up with the business goals
as closely as possible and that they
know their role in that you can also
know how often to cheer them on like how
best to motivate them some people react
better to a tough conversation others
that completely be motivates them so the
better you understand that the better
you can act everyday in the moment you
know as long as you're thinking about it
consciously then you can you can make
those decisions hmm okay interest in so
what let's just let's just talk about
the the journey of harrassing cuz I
think there'll be lows in there that
obviously you're willing to share and it
was difficult at the start and I guess
let's just talk a bit about as you as
you've already said that your
circumstances when you're looking to
leave oligo were totally different to
when you joined I guess just if you were
to just add a bit more wrong because I
think a lot of people as you know John
Locke by that point over the heads what
an idiot
eleven years recruitment experience
Doretta obviously clearly approving
recruits a villa like you would be
getting tapped out every single day by
rhetorics right trying to spin your head
go and join you consider this blah blah
blah so I guess and just quickly on that
like what did you make sure that you
found out that you saw that you got from
Bob Harrison or when he was in that
interview process that just really helps
you be confident that Harrison was the
place for you because I think that can
be really difficult for a lot of
recruiters that know that they want to
progress their career know that they
want a new challenge but right they just
obviously they can't get their head
turns so much so I guess what what did
you sort of do in that process that made
you confident in the decision that you
made
that's a good question we give people
advice on this stuff as recruiters
you're always telling people you know
you're helping people uncover their why
and what's most important to them and
stuff like that it takes a bit of
different thinking to do it to yourself
but it'd been on my mind for quite a
while I've had many sleepless nights
thinking about it you know to a degree
walking away from something that you
then build and become a director
orbiters put your name on his could be
seen as failure to certain people so
there's always that in the back of your
mind I kind of recap'd on what was
important to me it felt like I wanted to
be a part of something bigger remember
that you only live once there's no dress
rehearsal here so you want to make the
most of it while you're here
so what I looked for was was firstly
just smart people to work with and when
it's a work with people I could learn
from and maybe I've got to the point in
my career where I didn't feel like I was
growing much anymore mmm I think that
was bothering me I didn't look around
the room and see loads of people that I
thought I really want to be you I really
want to spend time with you and on a
personal level absolutely some fantastic
people and some really good recruiters
but I just felt like I needed to level
up so when I met the guys in pop
Harrison and the wider group there's a
lot of very very capable leaders a lot
of very good recruiters people that you
know I've really learned from in the
last couple of years so I think I felt
like if I could find the right people
and when I met Tom the CEO he just said
learn it's a rocket ship don't worry
about exactly what seat you get and just
get on actually I thought you know what
that's kind of if I find the right
people the right environment and
hopefully combine that with me backing
myself to to do the rest it will be a
good marriage and was that just love so
how you put that because I think a lot
of people will find themselves in that
position I mean the majority of the UK
recruitment industry is subtend staff
and yeah I think that that must that
must have been such a sort of
and a back-and-forth review personally
because we've got John guess been there
for eight years everyone will know you
like done really great but then if
you've got no one around you inspiring
you or sort of pushing you to level up
your game or whatever that must have
been so hard to leave that because that
that really is comfortable isn't it and
it's you know we need to do day in day
out if you do this there's a good chance
I'm gonna own this this year so big fair
play to return to making that leap and I
guess like for you obviously I'm I feel
like it was more than just being around
people that was billing more than you it
it was more than that
he's becoming a better leader as well
yeah yeah I wanted to learn from people
I think that the recruitment part always
come fairly well pretty successful and
safe build well starting to grow a team
had never really got past a certain
level so I wanted to go and learn from
people have done that and there's whole
host of different brands characters
offices one thing you do get with the
business I work for now is everyone's
always willing to talk and help yes but
we don't hire people that are arrogant
and keep themselves to themselves
everyone is stronger together it's like
a family so now when I met started to
meet people I think I had five or six
interviews in the end it was quite a
lengthy process that did help with the
thinking and the reassurance yeah
because I was going to say like how did
you cuz I feel like a lot of people will
sort of resonate with that that actually
you know what that is what I'm looking
for or I'm wanting to level up but how
did you go about fishing that out of
people when you met them because that
can be quite hard to do Conor was it
just got indistinct I think yeah I found
their sudden about anyone else but the
longer you work you learn to trust your
gut more you know you can back it up
with data you can go and find facts and
do your homework
but normally what you got tells you is
very close and if it isn't it's not the
end of the world anyway you can always
make a change and if you can hover the
attitude towards the whole recruitment
world as the you either win or you learn
I think that helps every single day I
with the title of the podcast right it
is a rollercoaster
some days are awful you get one phone
call that literally changes whether you
can go on holiday another phone call
that surprises you out of nowhere even
though you've managed the process really
well
you don't think someone's going to get
the job when they do it can be a bit on
like a knife edge so I think yeah
focusing on the things you can control
gonna take the attitude out of it that
if you do trust your gut and you do get
it wrong it's not it's not the end that
helped okay so what was that sorry to
your question yeah oh yeah that's that's
bang on so I guess let's talk about
those first six months then because yeah
as you said already John guests top dog
as a team right got into a brand new
market right new sets a new niche that
you've never done before
as you said into a company that as a
type the job taught that you had
typically I'm assuming because you said
that that typically would be they'd grow
that they'd grow those people internally
yeah so they should talk about that
because I think a lot of people again
would would have to go through that or
might have experienced out or might be
thinking about making a move and this
might be one of the things that's their
biggest concern so firstly the market
that must have been really difficult to
leave as well because you've worked so
hard to build that out now inside out so
what what was the mindset going in early
on as to learning and you also you know
how important it is to sort of know and
understand the nuances of your market
and how that can be part of your
competitive advantage yeah but like what
was your mindset going into that go in
right on know fuck-all about this
industry like what was the mindset to
start really obstacle in yourself in it
well firstly it wasn't as hard as I
thought it was gonna be okay
my wife's dead which might contradict
each other
I did you kind of have FOMO fear of
missing out on your last market when
you've got a cut the umbilical cord then
you've got no choice
I loved my old market it was great I
knew loads of people I'd go to an event
and you probably know approaching half
the people in the room you'd know and
they know you which was great but did
you get referrals and the networking
dinner over i'ma talk to you and you
became a part of the sector rather than
a an accessory but I wanted to change
and Kanaan's when you I think as long as
I can get interested in the sector more
than just the money but at the sector
that I recruited an interested name then
that was important and we're constantly
working in London placing people ons of
projects mainly in London where you're
actually involved in shape and what the
future of the city is going to look like
that's pretty cool excited you yeah
where are those buildings you can take
people that you've hired and say look I
client
they've built this they've just let it
out there just sold it you know you're
really involved in the sector so my
mindset was now I've recruited in a part
of property by building services so more
maintenance
now I'm recruiting for more project
management which I kind of knew so I
knew what I knew can that it looked like
from a non technical point of view and I
think most niches are never going to
know all of the technical intricacies
anyway so you've got back your so for
knowing a process I just went and asked
as many questions to as many people as
possible I think in my first year I went
on 81 wire meetings
Wow notice that so in two week pretty
much go out and meet clients that we'd
all had a relationship with at some
point or that were completely new and
just ask them as many questions as
they'd let me before they kick me out I
love that and what was the answer
what was the intention then was it just
like hey like I don't know I'm new here
at Harrison I don't know what how did
you pray like because not a lot of
people like to let people know that
they're new and they don't they're not
knowledgeable
didn't necessarily go in and say look I
know nothing about it can I come and
meet you pretty busy but find a way to
build rapport any time a company would
say they're looking for someone which in
certain parts of the market because it
was quite candid it led a lot of
companies were looking they work they're
a bit frustrated with their recruitment
partners or first national it was there
was a [ __ ] in their armor you could
then explore and then the minute they
started talking I just made it part of
operations that before you start working
with you will come down and spend time
in you just made it I think I work with
a sales coach for a little while and one
of the things he said to me was if you
whoever's persons in stronger will win
whoever's process if the buyers
processed stronger than the sellers
process they'll be okay if you are
selling to someone you have a stronger
process they'll typically be happy to be
led mmm understand it so if part of your
process is that people meet you normally
people will go along with that and if
they don't there might be a different
reason they might not be the best
clients to work with anyway so I didn't
actually find a huge amount of
resistance and bearing in mind I was in
London everyday within 15 minute walk of
most of these companies it was fairly
easy to be flexible I could be the first
thing last thing lunchtime spent quite a
lot of money on coffee but equally I've
never worked in London before so it's
great to find out you know more about
the city I've walked at every meeting
where possible so I can see along the
way what sites are in construction and
write down the names because every star
every sites got like a board on the
front yeah he's working on it I also
found where as good venues for canvas
and clients to meet so yeah I just
soaked it all up as much as possible I
love that and then and then the other
part that I'd love to get your thoughts
on is war
what was your mindset to ensure that as
you said going in because this could be
part of the pressure that a lot of
people worried about right if I'm
I'm known and well respected in my
current company but if I was to move
I've won a decent level position but I
don't know any of the people not going
to have this or respect straight away
that I currently have so I know you sort
of touched on it but like what was what
was your mindset towards making sure
that you wasn't perceived as a [ __ ]
coding into the new company do not I
mean income that is my position that
typically people don't do how did you
make sure that internally you was
perceived in the wrong way or yeah what
was your full process just just don't be
well yeah sounds easy and that's a bit
of a flip and comment just be kind
thoughts people view I we were based in
a we work shared kitchen any time I was
out there try and say hello find out
what people do make sure I understand a
mess as possible which was a real
challenge it probably took me a good
month or two to know who everyone was
yeah join in with events get that on the
pub get to know people outside of work
during work hours if you're going to
make things work I think you need to be
pretty focus you need to be pretty
planned you haven't got time necessarily
to be you know the office butterfly
fluttering around yes but outside of
that there's no excuse for not being
kind and did and what just give me a bit
of context did you inherit a team then
like did you help people to manage
straightaway yeah so I had a couple of
people straightaway and both had
experience in recruitment I think one
person that was supposed to be my team
ended up by moving to Australia well I
was working my notes experience I was
gonna have three ended up of two so I
inherited a team and one of them had
been with the business quite a long time
strong character they were not doing
that sector
she'd done on another sector and she'd
moved into the sector okay he had
previous but slightly different to what
the core of the team was know so that
helped I mean I could same same approach
we they've asked him as many questions
as possible about what they need okay
gage what if it was real
how much of it was perception hmm so
really difficult first six months saying
because obviously clearly really tried
to go back the right way right mindset
learn as much as possible but it took
you six months to really get going yeah
how the fight to get through that then
because that's because that 100% you'll
be having self-doubt like I'm not gonna
add an am I'm going to keep my job of I
even got any respect like what what made
you push on I focus on the things that I
can contrive always been pretty good at
that I don't take the losses too
seriously so yes I did doubt myself but
not massive amount I was
now have a book of I've written down
things I'm grateful for I try and
document some of my wins if I'm ever in
a bad place I'll have a bad day that's a
good place to go
love that now I have a son it's a lot
easier because he's kind of around
especially during lockdown spending time
and then it kind of reminds you why you
do this and that but good watch an hour
of Peppa Pig will take you back to just
gives you perspective yeah for me I
think because in my sector before the
fees were a lot lower he's talking
average fee of five grand maybe so I
think from memory in my best year and my
business before I did my approaching 60
deals so more than one a week and to go
then after doing none for that period of
time what's difficult really here I had
a couple of offers that didn't close
because I hadn't really I think maybe
the self-doubt manifested itself ended
up asking some of the tougher questions
which definitely do now I see it as a
positive but that made me level up again
it made me look at the process and also
that of the team kind of break it down
and build it back up again and you were
dealing with much higher fees much
higher salaries in hindsight I wish I'd
moved to a higher salaries higher fees
sooner because I think it is actually
easier in many ways IP
take the whole process more seriously
but there is a clear difference in terms
of an engineer's mindset to a quantity
surveyors mindset terms of like if you
had a graph of all the people's
personalities there would definitely be
a difference so it's just learning to
try and adapt to giving more detail try
asking questions that people you could
feel that they were afraid to ask you
something but you might discuss over it
to start with and really remembering why
some of the things that got you where
you got to yeah and then what do you
think changed them was it just
confidence was it just as you said
getting back to basics taking the time
to look at the process you know what I
should have asked that question next
time I'm definitely to ask it and then
just like recruitment does right it just
it clicks doesn't it and and as soon as
you start feeling confident you just
start flying yeah so what was it just
the combination of sort of all that
hardship and you having the mindset of
you know what let's look at my process
what did I do wrong there what can I
learn from that then just gave you the
best possible chance of getting that
turning point yeah I mean the business
supported me I think they could see that
I was doing all the right things and it
was going to come and the same when
you're leading someone as long as
somebody's turning up every day has the
right attitude and they're learning from
those mistakes you know that they can
make it it's when one of those two
things slips away however the effort
goes the attitude goes or and keep doing
the same things over and over again
that's when it tends to be a struggle
hmm there's a lot easier jobs to do to
earn a basic salary definitely so ended
up doing well back into the first year
qualified for the Bahamas trip so what
why didn't you go why can you go on that
my dad ended up coming to go to the
hospital saying he is forever to blame
for that
he was okay led to him having to have
like a five heart bypass Wow
yeah so he was in in and out of
intensive care last year for three
months which was another tough period
like working and going to hospital but
would he's longer met there's been okay
during this period he took a bit of
convincing to go into lockdown but he's
been pretty good since he just for its
classic yeah I'll be right John
we in the world when you've been through
stuff like that makes you quite
philosophical a beer I've so you either
go one of two ways where they you
probably either I've really worried or
you just like to know what whatever
happens happen exactly he's definitely
the latter I get some of it from like
focusing all the things you can control
yeah and I know that's sort of real
common advice but like when you really
do that and you like really let that
sink in like that's that that's what I
Eve I definitely like so for me I ended
up back and my back at home in
Eastbourne living my girlfriend's
parents their family home because I've
got a flat in London and it's been
horrible to work from home and it just
thought it was really difficult because
I have my routine was working in an
office and all that and then I was found
myself working in a dining-room table at
my girlfriend's parents was like is this
real life like what the [ __ ] going on
and just I just really you can really
get caught quite easily and focusing and
thinking about the things that you can't
control and the issues of loop and but
when you actually take a step back and
well actually what what kind of
controlling to only focus on those
things it just it just really makes you
feel lighter and sort of puts weight off
your shoulders
yeah so I know you said that a couple of
times but like it's it's great
yeah and focus on the things that I can
control its like that are you like did
you know I mean it's it's one of them
and for the second year then let's talk
about that and then sort of talk a bit
about what's been going on for you and
how you been approaching things recently
but so I'm assuming then going to the
second year confidence and was excited
what
when on a second-year but I mean first
year ended well second year we started
to build out the team and we didn't
quite hit the record for the brand but I
think we're pretty close to it the
second full year which was kind of up
until February again I think we achieved
50% growth mmm in terms of GP year and
year so it's going well and this year
actually started pretty well as well and
then obviously the world change building
or recognition
kind of overnight and again going back
to focusing on the things you can
control there's a lot right now that you
can't think if you read too much if you
spend too much time online watch too
much news right now you'll probably fill
your head with the wrong things it's not
what I mean you should be naive to
what's going on because there's things
that are important and protests over the
last week or two for me has been a like
handle heart I'm uneducated you know I
yeah I've got some learning to do and
I'm spending some time doing that to
make it a bit more in my control in
terms of understanding but there is a
lot right now going on that is not
necessarily super positive I have seen
some people maybe suffer a little bit by
focusing too much on those things
whereas if an even speaking to that
people have in the market it feels like
some recruiters have maybe gone back
into their shell and just stand right
we'll call you after the summer I feel a
bit bad about talking to you right now I
feel people need your help more than
ever right now no candidates in need
business owners that are trying to
navigate this like we all are
unprecedented being like the term that
everyone's using but never seen anything
like this the global financial crisis
was not like this if some company still
did well everyone can still meet well
it's totally different it is different
there's the whole distance some
industries it's just such a jigsaw to
put back together but if you focus too
much on that stuff it could stop
affecting your ability to hit your goals
and you might need to adjust what those
goals are but I think as long as you're
turning up every day in your plan then
you're speaking to people you still
having to calm
evidence that people would want to hear
from you from my own experience people
do and actually they really value your
advice right now they might not be
recruiting they might not want to talk
about a role but trust me they want to
know about what's going on in the market
because they're at home they're on their
own they're probably a bit lonely
they've spoken to their peers but not
outside of the group
I haven't been to many networking events
so again like an example for now I think
if you focus on just having
conversations with the view of trying to
help people
lonely you'll go far wrong and how have
you gone about helping people then
because I think some regret I've done
this really well but how have you
approached it I've put put some stuff
out video content out LinkedIn for job
seekers that recorded interview last
week which we're gonna pair with Andrew
McCaskill talking about some of the
things people can be doing so for those
people that are coming to me asking for
help as a job seeker I wanted to be able
to give them self I think if I can't
give them as much of my time as I'd like
because around a two-year-old your days
on Lay's anymore we've done a guide so
remote onboarding which was been
well-received that we put out to a
number of our clients and people that
are not clients that we knew were hiring
to Saylor we know you know mostly this
stuff but hopefully this helps I've been
recording some podcasts with senior
people within my sector talking about
their journeys similar to your may them
to try and just give back to the
ecosystem like you're doing like you
have done ever since yeah for a long
time before this will happen just try to
bring value I've connected some clients
to each other so they can talk about
doing business together
mm-hm in a bit creative I mean no I love
that and I think and I think just
whoever's listening right now don't
people will remember what you do during
this period they just will and yeah I
think I think yes if you're all those
things that you're doing it enables you
to have touch points with people in your
market and everybody to get on the phone
speak to people and and that that's
really what what you need right now and
I think it can one of the most common
questions
from this or live podcast of webinars of
the last relates while wheels was the
business development piece I'm thinking
to me quite difficult Carnac because
we've gone through that period of like
you've probably if you've called someone
a couple of times and gone hey John how
you doing just checking in blah blah
blah for me only so much you can still
do that but like for that to be the only
reason you're calling could be a bit you
might be like now I just call in so I
think doing so I think it's like not
forgetting what I keep reminding people
is the recruiters that I work with other
branding this stuff is like don't forget
that one of the biggest sort of the the
value that you can bring right now is
that you're speaking to a lot of people
like John that's having the headaches
that someone down the road is having but
they have no idea that they're going
through that as well yeah and that's
what you're just talking about right
it's it's enabling people to share and
talk about their challenges or what
they're doing so other people know and
understand it's not just they're going
through that and that's one of the great
lights about connecting people right and
that's one of the things you can do
right now through all different ways and
so that I love that that's awesome and
what's been what's been some of those
sort of biggest challenges for you then
John clearly sort of spend a lot of time
developing yourself and mentally and
professionally clearly what what's been
as you mentioned your two year-olds
couple of times so I can imagine that's
a whole another challenge never had
before but how it would have been the
biggest challenges for you um I think
managing a team remotely is is a
challenge my wife actually manages a
team off in the UK and half in Poland so
she so she's been really good in terms
of just being normal but trying to
understand how people are really feeling
is a bit more difficult when you're very
screen ya got a different situation
everyone's got a different set up some
people are probably enjoying it some
people are people it's always a worry
that if people tell you that they're
struggling that it could be seen
negatively so we try to be as as I up
front with that as possible it is
nothing remember everyone's got a
different challenge right now navigating
the whole business development piece is
going to change trying to get
that's right between still doing
activity but also expressing empathy
yeah though you know we were talking
earlier this week about language to use
in emails and follow-ups and trying to
not seem insensitive but at the same
time not overthink it so you don't do
anything yeah
content coming up with ideas I know I
think I saw one of your polls that
that's probably people's biggest
challenge is coming up with ideas of
where to even start
yeah something that everyone struggles
with I think just right every time you
have an idea write it down put it in a
central place and if something keeps
appearing then there's probably some
value in it and actually things you talk
about all the time which are probably a
bit boring to you people that they work
in recruitment don't talk about all the
time plus as we're doing it all via
video and you're not standing up in
front of people if you're not happy with
it you can just rerecord it I'm also a
bit like my speech at my wedding I
probably got wrong about four times but
no one you didn't know what I was
supposed to say so just try and have a
bit of fun with it so we're trying to
encourage our team to be active on
social and have a bit of a presence to
remind people that we're still there for
them still there yeah not try and be
insensitive by pretending nothing's
going on hmm I think the sort of
motivation and the managing team
remotely has been hard for a lot of
people and again a real common question
that people have I guess is there been
anything that you've sort of implemented
or made non-negotiable in your weeks
that have sort of impacted that do you
think a hope so we have a kickoff every
day we have a wrap-up every day as a
team everyone has to have their video on
which we've got that lapse on but we've
brought it back we are doing socials
we've done quizzes we're having our
Friday sales meeting at the end of the
week as a whole company which I've
hosted a few times for for Europe so
that normally involves highlights of the
week they have a wrap-up of where we're
at in terms of performance some of the
challenges update on the office if you
find games competitions people win
prizes so we've sent like lunch to
people's houses we've
seven bottles of wine just tried to keep
them connected I don't think when you
talk to people out in the market some
people that are liking at home even if
they haven't been furloughed or some
people that have been furloughed just
that not being communicated with mm-hmm
and that leads to worry I don't think
you can be commuting communicating too
much right now
so we've tried to get the balance right
but you know I'm not the person to judge
whether that's successful or not but it
feels like people have taken things
positively yeah I think I think one of
the again a common challenge has been
that sort of you've probably got us
speaking if you're checking in with me
and going eh man find an air and what's
going on and I'm saying John you know
what I've had a good day blah blah blah
but there's just something any gun not
sure and it's hard to gauge that I mean
one of the things that came out of the
it was during the Mental Health Week was
I thought was great it was really simple
was asked how they are twice is that it
is a good yeah because I mean how often
does that happen one but normally issues
so easy for me to go hey John how you
gonna go and it's just so easy sort of
give me a sort of subconscious response
was like yeah I'm okay but there's
another John how are you just love well
actually yeah how the [ __ ] am I so know
that response for that question
hmm yeah making the best of it that's
what I normally say right now trying to
make the best of the situation we're in
but that that's probably just my stock
answer rather so I mean yeah we don't
probably take that approach to
recruitment do it if someone if you ask
someone why they want to leave and they
say progression probably you know they
wanna dig a bit deeper wouldn't you to
understand what's underneath there's
probably a couple of levels below
something that's a really good tip no
and then just just before we finished
John cuz I'm sure there'll be a lot of
parents that listen to this what I've
said no when we before we started this
you said it'd be a miracle if I don't
get interrupted just yeah obviously yeah
you've got a two-year-old you've got
obviously a wife that's working as well
I guess however you have you have
that it was tough to start with yeah we
just sit down every day and draw a plan
out for the relay to the to the exact
minute who's got calls when her job
involves quite a lot just the host
webex's and conference calls with lots
of people involved so I try and be a
little bit more fluid and then in the
days that which is a bit quieter other
days that I know I've got time for
you're just try and book as many calls
as possible I think that is a really
good tip for for people anyway
in booking a call with someone even if
it's in your own team managers
expectations sets the precedent allows
you to prepare if you're booking a call
with a client it also helps with
positioning yeah as in get it in the
diary don't you say yeah John I'll call
you later today yeah they keep by
working half of a day or two thirds of a
day in a month looking after to you does
really focus your mind on what's
important to go out of each day and you
need to be productive I really struggle
with other start fitting in and out
because I feel like recruitment you kind
of find your flow when you do business
development or you're like focusing on
the tasks you kind of get into it
imagine that being trimmed down to 45
minutes so the star was struggling but
now kind of I've got better
understanding of what I can fit into
that time so therefore I can manage my
own expectations a little bit better be
a bit less tough for myself for and I
don't get everything done you know this
won't be forever
have you found switching off I think
people talk about work/life balance and
I think there's nothing wrong with
having working in the evenings if it's a
choice so try and take some time off we
try and go for a walk at the end of the
day every day and take him out get some
fresh air up and we've done a we've
created a running club group and in the
office we've committed to run 2,000
kilometers in June between us so try to
get out exercise let's try and start the
day or in the day bit like I think what
you said in one of your other interviews
by having a defined point but there
normally will cleanse easily have dinner
and then choose whether to switch back
on or not but try and have it for a
defined period yeah I found it okay hmm
I think it's the what you said about if
it's a choice then you're comfortable
with that yeah love that and so John
what what are you excited about we
excited about postcodes professionally
personally well are you excited about
I'm excited about but like just chilling
in a beer garden with my mates give them
a hug when I see them I'm definitely
excited about that seeing people I think
most people in recruitment are social
creatures and video is great who didn't
have video this would be a lot tougher
I'm excited about that
so I had to go on holiday again at some
point in the future well though this
year we were only planning to go in the
UK anyway I'm excited for the
opportunities that this will bring I
think having worked through the GFC on
the back of that there was some growth
and the people that were still there and
still fighting and still able to carry
on through it or maybe they didn't break
any records but they kept the lights on
were the people that then it paid them
back so I think now our CEO uses the
phrase recruitments in the post so a lot
of the stuff you're doing right now if
it doesn't give you that interesting
result it's trying to just make sure
that you're conscious that it's gonna
pay you back at some point I was like
the crazy excited to see what the future
brings post all the best place it's a
terrible thing to happen and it's by no
means positive at all but you know there
may be some positives out of it like
flexibility for a lot of people being
less of a stigma as one recruitment in
the post recruitments in the post
recruitment in the post I love that so
the last question you can answer this
with a phrase ascendance of words
whatever comes up for you but if John
guest could communicate every single
recruiter out there they'd listen
they're taken an advice that implemented
tomorrow what would you say to the
people hmm
just one thing you win all you learn
take that attitude into every day and I
I think you'll you'll make you make it
pretty far I love that John John has
been an absolute pleasure thank you XE
show